dude I'm up here now what am I doing  here crying well no what are you doing  up there what have you done bro  okay all right fine okay okay you shoot  that portal there I'm gonna go through  there no no no I got a platform I got a  pen  already done yeah I got the plan ready  guys no you shoot Paula listen to me  listen to me no no no [ __ ] bro there no  no no don't shoot me  no no sure Puma you should follow that  you should run that you should see you  shoot you you should you should you  already shot you should you should you  should I will cry cry cry cry cry do you  remember what September did  oh there's a thing over here and see  that you see this I do actually  [Music]